the digital economy is breaking things
because most people running digital
companies aren't aware of the operating
system that's beneath what they're doing
you know there's a good old-fashioned
venture capital driven operating system
no it's it goes back to central currency
and corporatism and chartered monopolies
and really the way our economy works
which is worked for a good four or five
hundred years and promoted everything
from the British East India Trading
Company right through to Walmart and
General Electric but when you take that
and juice it up with digital steroids
weird things start to happen you know
you end up able to tweak and optimize
your business so carefully that you can
really see is it growing is it not
growing what can we do to promote growth
growth growth and if your company's not
growing you end up in big trouble
against all the other players that are
growing no it's simple power law
dynamics it's a winner-takes-all
landscape so if you have a company like
Twitter which I would see in my
old-fashioned view as a successful
company it makes five hundred million
dollars a quarter based on a hundred and
forty character app success right no in
the current environment that's a failure
because they don't have a growth
strategy they don't know how to turn
into a video company a news company a
social company than everything company
and the reason why the digital economy
is breaking our businesses is because
we're taking the old agenda of growth
and running it on digital platforms and
it ends up amplifying and spinning this
priority out of control most of us look
at the industrial age as this natural
outgrowth of the need to do more and
better business but as I researched it I
found out that most of the innovations
we came up with
the Industrial Age were really for the
opposite there was a thriving
peer-to-peer economy right at the end of
the Middle Ages that nobody likes to
talk about the soldiers had come back
from the Crusades they had all sorts of
new inventions and technologies and
mechanisms they were new trade routes
that they had opened up and they came
back to their towns and they took
something that they found in the Middle
East called the bazaar and they revived
it as something they called the
marketplace so now people who had just
been peasants working on the land of the
Lord's started coming together in
trading the stuff that they made and
they had all of these really interesting
instruments from market money and local
currency and grain based currency and
all of these evolved really to promote
the exchange of value and the velocity
of transactions between people and it
started to really do well which was the
problem as the peasant became wealthy
the aristocracy got scared who are these
people they're not going to be dependent
on us anymore
so they came up with two main financial
innovations to prevent the rise of this
peer-to-peer economy the first one was
the chartered monopoly really the parent
to the modern corporation all the
chartered monopoly was was a way to say
all of you small businesses are now
illegal if you want to be in the shoe
business you have to work for His
Majesty's royal shoe company you want to
be in the grain business you have to
work for His Majesty's royal grain
company so people who were small
business people now became employees
instead of selling the value they
created now they sold their time as
servants as wage labourers the second
invention they came up with was central
currency not such a terrible thing in
itself it's great to have a
long-distance currency that lots of
people can use in value but the problem
was they made all of the local
currencies illegal so the only way
people could trade with each other the
candlestick maker could trade with the
chicken farmer was by borrowing central
currency from the Treasury so now you
had to borrow money at interest just in
order to transact and that set in motion
really a growth cascade
if you have a currency that has to be
paid back with interest in order to just
to meet to make ends meet
you need an economy that's growing you
need more money next year than there was
this year so that worked well for
colonial powers as long as we can extend
into Africa and South American North
America
fine slaves find new resources we could
grow but what happens when you reach the
end of the planets growth as we did
really at the end of World War two well
then we started to look for really
virtual surface areas some new way to
grow and that was technology we believed
that digital technology in the World
Wide Web and computers would really
create a new place a new virtual
territory for us to colonize and it just
turns out what we've been colonizing for
the last 20 years is human attention and
human time and now it looks like we're
even running out of that well when the
internet first emerged people like me
thought hooray now we're going to have a
way to restore all that peer-to-peer
connectivity between people and some of
the earliest internet businesses
actually sought to do that in one way or
another if you look at the path of you
know eBay and PayPal and Etsy and square
there are a lot there are a lot of
businesses that are looking at how can
we connect people in a lateral way the
problem is as those businesses grew and
everybody got interested in the net
other folks the folks who really who
started Wired magazine or the global
business network a lot of folks who were
from the old Nasdaq Stock Exchange which
had been really depleted ever since the
biotech crash of 1987 they saw in the
internet a new avenue for growth so for
them it wasn't about how are we going to
connect people in new wonderful ways and
let them create an exchange value
between them it was really more how can
we use digital platforms to extract
value from people in places so if you
compare an eBay which is promoting
exchange to an Amazon which is promote
traction you can kind of begin to see
the difference what happens is you end
up with digital businesses that really
are started more in the flip this house
model of business then I'm going to
start a business that helps people and
keeps going for 20 years people put
money into an internet business in order
to get to acquisition or IPO they want
to grow this business a hundred times
and then get out it's called an exit
strategy then it doesn't matter what
happens so if you have a ride-sharing
company are you going to pay your
drivers enough so that they can have an
ecosystem that lasts 20 years no you
don't care about that you can adopt a
scorched-earth policy towards this
because you only need those drivers and
that whole ride-sharing sector long
enough to establish a monopoly and then
move over into something else when the
internet came around we all thought
we're all going to get to work at home
and our underwear in our own time
exchanging valet with one another but
instead we've ended up with an internet
that takes more time from us an Internet
that we feel exhausted and drained when
we're done using it and that's because
we're not using it it's using us these
the Internet is really just the
technological front on a whole series of
business plans that are looking to
extract money from us time from us
attention from us and if we have none of
those things
at least data from us and we're not
feeling it creating value for us we're
not feeling it really enhance our
ability to create an exchange value with
other people it's harder for most of us
to make a living now rather than easier
and that's not because automation is
doing things better it's because we're
really facing very extractive business
plans extensions of that very same late
medieval squashing of peer-to-peer
activity although now amplified in every
device in our arsenal the reason I'm
optimistic is because the metrics are
all on the side of doing business well
rather than this
earth short-term extractive model that
most digital companies use if you look
at the data family businesses do better
than shareholder owned businesses on
every single metric except one they grow
slower during bubbles and actually you
kind of want to want to grow slower
during bubbles because if you grow big
during a bubble then you're part of what
pops now the reason why family
businesses do better in the long run
then shareholder owned businesses is
because the person running a share the
person running a family business wants
it to be around in another generation or
two or three the person running a
shareholder owned business wants to
extract enough money from that business
so their grandchild can be given this
wad of cash the person with a family
business wants the business to be
healthy enough so the grandchild can
then run a successful thriving business
and because your family name is on the
business you don't want to do really
mean things to your employees or to the
places where you operate because then
people are going to hate your family you
know it's your name it's your face so a
very very different dynamic get set up
and one that's ultimately more
sustainable as a business you know and
startup the founders of startups and
technology businesses have to come to
understand that taking venture capital
and going for the big acquisition going
for that one out of 10,000 chance of
getting a home run is dumb compared to
taking a very small amount of money and
hitting the single or the double in
other words making 10 or 20 million
dollars is not tragic it's still enough
you can still really you're going to get
by on that you're going to be able to
send your kids to great colleges it's
not a failure to have millions of
dollars but if you have to aim for the
billions if you are forced to your
probability is so low you know when I
look at these founders running to
Sequoia and Flatiron and Y Combinator
because they want to go big and get the
home run it looks to me like those P
you see taking their welfare checks and
going to the bodega and buying lottery
tickets because they want to get the
jackpot the 43 million they have no
chance of doing that and they would have
a chance of taking their five or ten
dollars and actually investing it in buy
a book learn how to do something get a
job they have a much more high
probability of succeeding and it just
breaks my heart when I see a kid have a
great app a great idea and then they
turn to a venture capitalist who gives
them a ton of money and a high valuation
and then has them pivot the pivot is not
to do something better
all the pivot means is you're going to
abandon what your original business was
in order to come up with something
that's sellable to the next round of
investors the next round of suckers
really and do you really want to throw
away your business do you really want to
dispose of your idea in order to turn it
into the the brand name on a Ponzi
scheme you know I hope not because
there's still so many great things we
can do with these technologies there's
so much money to be made there's so much
there's so much revenue in creating
people to one another and helping people
create an exchange value you know the
mantra I would give any startup and any
big business is make other people rich
if you make your users rich they will
come back if you make them poor you've
killed your marketplace
you